hi everyone my name is mirti singh and
i'm a final year undergraduate who's an
nlp researcher by profession
um
right now my domain of interest is
applying nlp for social good initiatives
and health care objectives so
today i am here to talk about um
nlp and hate speech and why does it
matter and what we can do about it
so
for those of you who haven't already
seen the outline of my talk let me just
give you an overview of what we are
going to be discussing in the next 30
minutes
uh first i'm going to start off by
introducing hate speech what it means
and what are the most common forms of
hate speech that we see today
i'm going to move on then to in
explaining why the detection of heat
speech is important and why
it's a popular field in the research
community
and then i'm going to show you a couple
of use cases
for why machine learning has been used
for hate speech detection and why deep
learning has been used for its page
detection and then we are going to look
at both of these use cases and sort of
have a contrastive analysis to figure
out you know when to use machine
learning and when to use deep learning
and finally i'm going to show you a few
open source data sets and libraries that
you can use to develop your own models
that contribute to this course
so with that let's get started
uh hate speech is a pretty intuitive
term right but a formal definition is
an abusive or threatening speech or
writing that expresses prejudice against
a particular group especially on the
basis of gender race religion or sexual
orientation
so just from that definition you can
tell what are the common forms of hate
speech that we are seeing today sexism
racism
and you know stuff like that
and
the reason this is becoming such a big
problem
is
a bit of a complex thing so let me
explain it to you a little in real life
you wouldn't expect anybody to you know
just walk up to you and say something
really rude or something really
offensive and just get away with it
right that's not how that works because
you know that there'd be consequences
for that nobody could just get away with
that
but unfortunately with the many many
advantages that social media platforms
have brought about with um you know like
networking privileges
they have also bought about the
so-called cloak of anonymity and what
this means is that somehow people are
more comfortable saying things they
shouldn't be saying as long as they can
say it online from behind the screen
because it
devoids them of any accountability and
any consequences for their actions
and to give you some context into the
scale of this problem right
uh the cto of facebook once said that
they had to take action against 4.6
million posts that had hateful content
in just one week so yeah that's how big
of a problem this is
and it like you know you might wonder
why does this even matter you know like
how does it matter who is saying what
online
here's the thing though our entire lives
are happening online
right um
especially after the onset of the covert
19 pandemic we find that our education
is happening online our work is
happening online so it does matter it
does matter to the victims who are
receiving insults and offensive route
comments publicly about things they have
no control over
it definitely matters to the victims who
are being threatened sometimes on public
platforms like twitter and facebook
and the thing is hate speech is usually
against minorities
so
it doesn't
make sense that they have to you know
withstand this kind of
what should i say behavior may be
and there's actually enough
psychological evidence to show that
speech causes psychological damage like
it causes actual damage sorry about that
yeah
so um the famous hollywood actress right
ashley judd she started something called
the speech project and she gave a ted
talk a few years ago in which she very
well
very nicely explained how
neurobiologically
we have the same reaction to
threats that are received online or
offline like it makes no difference to
us from a psychological standpoint
and there have been cases to
show for you know in some cases like the
extreme cases where these public uh you
know offensive statements or threats
have turned into hate crimes they've
turned into violence sometimes people
have died so by looking into hate speech
and like you know solving the problem of
hate speech detection
you might actually be contributing to
saving lives
and so
let's look at the challenge from a
technical standpoint here
one thing is definitely the scale of
social media right there's no way
that
a team of people will be enough to solve
this problem manually because there are
billions and billions of social media
users and there's so much of content
being generated every second like even
right now as we speak i'm sure there are
millions of posts being generated on
social media
so
we need ai for this problem right and
more specifically we need natural
language processing
and uh even more technically looking at
the challenge using natural language
processing to
capture the
you know semantic context that
signifies hatred and being able to
identify it
in a completely automated manner is the
challenge and it's further complicated
by linguistic complexities
like
context and sarcasm and metaphors and
you know sometimes people
use bad words in a way that is not meant
to be offensive that sort of stuff
uh there is one more issue that is
currently beyond the scope of this talk
and it is
that the
in some countries right especially the
united states of america the right to
free speech is protecting hate speech so
like it's not a crime
to say something hateful because it
comes under the right to free speech and
this is obviously very debatable
ethically but
even though i'm not going to go into it
right now i just wanted to you know
point out that this is also an issue so
for now let's move on to machine
learning and nlp for hate speech
detection and before we proceed i just
want to say that there has been a lot of
research done in this field
right and
in the interest of time i've just picked
out a couple of innovative solutions
that i thought would you know really
showcase how the field is developing
so with that being said let's move on to
this project that started at cornell
university
so researchers at cornell decide
determined that
not all offensive languages hate speech
like i said context plays a big role in
these things the difference between hate
speech and offensive language is just
that context so
what i mean by that is
sometimes offensive language like terms
that are typically construed as
offensive language they are used in
contexts that are not supposed to be
insulting you know like maybe you talk
to your friends or maybe you know
someone is
being sarcastic not all offensive
language is hate speech so
that's why the
researchers at cornell university
decided to have three categories for
their text classification problem which
is hateful offensive and neither
so
for their data set they collected a
lexicon from hatebase.org and then they
used terms from that lexicon to query
tweets using the twitter api
and i want to pause here for a second to
explain to you that
uh in the hate speech domain especially
tweets are
a standard data set uh platform like
what i mean to say is that you know most
of the hate speech data comes from
tweets and the reason this is so is that
i feel like twitter is the easiest uh
platform to access this type of content
and that's why you'll find that a lot of
work being done in heat speech usually
relies on some twitter data set so
anyway coming back to this project at
hand right uh they use the lexicon from
heatbase.org and they queried the tweets
and they got a really large data set so
they sub sub sampled some random part of
that data set and decided to have it
manually annotated through something
called crowdflower which is a platform
that specializes in data processing
and once they uh finished the manual
annotation process they found that only
five percent of the randomly sampled
tweets were considered hateful but that
was still
1240 tweets so again that just gives you
an idea of the scale of the problem that
we are dealing with
but anyways for the pre-processing
pipeline
the authors decided to convert all the
tweets to lower case you know clean up
the text and then for normalization they
used a quota stemmer algorithm that is
an algorithm which basically removes the
morphological and inflectional endings
of words and then
uh they generated engrams
according to the weights assigned by the
tfidf algorithm now for those of you who
aren't aware of this the tfidf is a
statistical algorithm that calculates
the importance of a word
in the in a collection of documents and
by documents i mean any corpus basically
so it does this by calculating two
things
how much a word occurs in a document and
how much it occurs across the entire set
of documents so it gives you a really
good idea of which words are
contextually important and which words
occur a lot and are contextually
irrelevant
so once they had a fully pre-processed
data set they used various supervised
machine learning algorithms like
logistic regression knife based
classifiers support vector machines and
they actually found that the best
performing model was a support vector
machine with an f score of 0.90
so that's a very high accuracy right
like that's 0.90 f score that's a really
great f score so i do urge you to check
out this paper in your free time and
i've put the link here in case you're
interested
but
yeah so this goes to show that you know
machine learning models are actually
doing really well at solving this
problem
but next i want to talk about a much
more recent issue right and that is
since the onset of the kovite 19
pandemic there has been an up rising of
xenophobia against the chinese community
and in a sense the broader asian
community and this has not only been uh
you know there's not just been an
increase in hate speech there have
actually been an increase in hate crimes
against asians as um you know
admitted by the fbi
so it's a pretty serious problem so it
makes sense then that uh the university
of georgia tech decided to come up with
a model that can detect
anti-asian covert 19 hate speech
so for this problem they define
anti-asian covert 19 hate speech as
antagonistic speech that has one or more
covet 19 key words is directed toward an
individual or group of asian people and
is abusive derogatory or assigns blame
for the creation and spread of poverty
so
let's move on and look at how they
proceeded about this
since this was a new problem to solve
right um the
researchers had to collect a data set
and they did that by looking at
um the twitter api again and they had a
list of keywords this time
and um they were able to
query three million tweets actually and
obviously that's too big so they ended
up randomly
sub sampling uh you know some part of
the data set and manually annotating
some part of that subset and then they
used a gender they generated a text
classifier to annotate the others this
is a common practice we see especially
when we are dealing with large scale
data sets because manual annotation
takes a lot of time and it's not simply
feasible most of the time
but
after they had their data set uh you
know they cleaned the text up and they
converted everything to lower case
and in this case what the researchers
did is that they decided to compare
glove embeddings and bottom embeddings
to see which one solves the problem
better and to give you a little bit of
context what word embeddings are in
general is basically a
vector representation of words with
context so what that means is that in a
vector space
words that have similar meaning will
have a similar representation and
they'll be closer to each other so in
this case you know maybe words that are
related to the 4-bit 19 pandemic are in
one cluster or you know they're closer
together in the vector space and um
words that are random like you know
maybe cat dog you know sky whatever
these words would be further apart so
there are different kinds of embeddings
generated by different models and gloves
and weddings and board embeddings are
two examples of this
and they found that bird embeddings suit
their problem statement better
so then they trained multiple supervised
algorithms again on these uh embeddings
and the data set that they have now
embedded dataset and they found that
although most of the classifiers right
like the logistic retesting knife base
random forest
all of them had almost the same
performance but they found that the
logistic regression classifier performs
a little bit better with an accu
accuracy of 0.86
and the metric they used is something
called auc roc which is basically a
graph that gives you area under the
curve of the receiver optimistic
characteristic
so what that means is that it basically
plots the true positive rate against the
false positive rate at
various
levels so it's a really accurate metric
and it's actually preferred over
accuracy and sometimes even over f score
actually depending on the problem
statement at hand
so once that's done
uh yeah i guess you can see now that you
know machine learning models are being
uh used very efficiently to solve this
problem of hate speech detection
and if you have any background in
machine learning already you know that
you know
uh
an
ensemble approach could go a long way
here so you might be wondering that okay
if individual classifiers are performing
so well
uh how well can an ensemble of these
classifiers perform
and this is actually a
question that motivated my own research
project
and currently it's under the paper is
under review but
yeah it turns out that ensembl models
can actually perform very well and
although our problem statement was a
little bit different initially like it
was more along the lines of cyber crime
prevention and threat detection
but uh definitely a part of our solution
proved that an ensemble of you know
knife based classifier support vector
machine random forest and decision tree
could actually outperform the
state-of-the-art architectures at sexism
detection and this includes the deep
learning architectures as well so we
achieved an accuracy of 97
on our hate speech detection data set
but
yeah i think one of the reasons this
works so well is that you know we were
able to leverage the benefits of the
wisdom of the crowd principle behind
ensemble learning uh combined with
algorithms that historically perform
well at text classification even though
they use you know diverse algorithms in
themselves so
yeah now
i guess all of this begs the question
why do we even need deep learning right
because if we're able to achieve um you
know
97 90 accuracy with just ensemble
learning and machine learning then do we
even need deep learning for this and the
short answer is yes because even in
general like in the field of ai deep
learning does a great job at solving
problems that are really really
complicated and you know have
constrained environments
uh in terms of the learning you know
conditions that are sort of in the
problem statement
so to give you some context of that
right let me talk about my first
publication
which was published at acl it's called
hold on honey men at work and uh we
basically wanted to detect sexism in
popular sitcoms
and we ended up using a semi supervised
approach for this and
it was actually a very complex problem
statement so let me give you some more
context of this we basically wanted to
build a model that can detect sexism and
dialogues of popular sitcoms
uh and
there were quite a few challenges for
this but the first one was that there
was very little data to work with in
that domain
right and
manual annotation is extremely time
consuming and sometimes it's not even
that efficient because of you know bias
that is bound to creep in
uh and then if we look at using another
domain which is what we ended up doing
anyway
the challenge was to you know being uh
challenges to being able to generalize
across
different domains then you know
the shows
even within sitcom to sitcom there's
going to be some linguistic difference
and then if you look for a domain that
actually has a lot of data uh you're
going to end up you know complicating it
linguistically it's going to be more
difficult to link have linguistic
generalization across domains so these
were some of the problems that we faced
and it turned out that the solution was
a combination of deep learning semi
supervised learning and transfer
learning
so i'm not going to get into uh
the methodology of my paper
for
you know in great detail for the
interest of time
but we did have three parts of our data
set and that did include tweets and the
reason we needed tweets was that we
needed to establish some sense of you
know
uh
training data for the baseline model
so we had tweets in there we took we
borrowed the tweets from benchmark hate
speech data set and we had manually
annotated dialogues and then we had a
combination of these two to generate
pseudo-labor dialogues so our final data
set consisted of three parts and even
then right it was a huge data set in the
ending but even then simple supervised
machine learning algorithms couldn't
give us an accuracy of 55 56
but on the other hand we used a
bi-directional lstm
uh on the baseline data set and we found
that the accuracy is 77
so you can see like you know how much of
an improvement there is and finally like
with the transfer learning and the
pseudo labeling techniques the
bile stem was able to achieve an
accuracy of around 80
so this is just going to show that you
know deep learning is necessary and it's
necessary
in places where the problem statement is
a lot more complex right
so i do have uh the link to the paper
here and you should definitely check it
out if this is something that interests
you because
this is a bit of a niche domain right i
mean we have a lot of work done on hp's
for social media but here's the thing
hate speech is not just on social media
it's everywhere right so this is one of
those papers that ventures to like be on
social media and still looks to detect
its speech so you should definitely
check it out
next i want to talk about something even
more interesting which is hate speech
detection in memes using something
called visual bird
so it's no secret then that today memes
are a very popular means of
communication in some cases even a
popular name for bonding
right and there was actually a challenge
called the hateful memes challenge where
there was you know the goal was to be
able to detect hate speech in memes
so obviously you can see that this is
one of those problems that combines
language and vision together right and
the challenge had hosted a name data set
of like 10 000 names that had to be
classified as either hateful or neutral
now this deviates a little bit from the
standard text classification task
because although it's hate speech
detection it's no longer just text
classification right uh if we are
looking to identify speech and names we
want to make sure that we're picking up
on visual cues and you know linguistic
cues so that's why obviously like you
can see how complicated a problem this
is and that's why visual board was
useful here which is a deep learning
architecture
so
you can see here like the lines that i'm
thinking along right like i want to be
able to show you that deep learning is
necessary for extremely complicated
problems
and so let's look into how this
approach was developed
uh firstly i want to point out the
difference between bird and visual world
and that difference is that the latter
is visually counted now what i mean by
that is that visual bird uses
transformers to jointly model words and
parts of images whereas like the
original board model was just meant to
you know model worlds
and even though visual world has
actually proved uh you know
highly successful at
many many tasks it's still a bit of a
question you know does it understand the
desired cross model representation
maybe maybe not you know
we have no way to say for sure so early
on in the research community
but
for this particular task right uh
the visual world model was
able to secure a score of 0.811
and it was the winning model so you can
see that deep learning is definitely
needed even in the hate speech detection
domain right and i'm not going into too
much depth and to explain how this
visual world model works or how you know
the methodology was devised because it's
a bit of a cross over between computer
vision and natural language processing
and
you know it will just take too long and
i've linked both of the papers below i
definitely think both of them are very
interesting and you know it's something
uh very different and something very
innovative so do check it out if you
have the time
uh one more thing that uh deep learning
and nlp are useful for
is the multilingual heat speech
detection
uh because the challenge in being able
to detect hate speech in multiple
languages is being able to use the same
architecture to understand and identify
hate's full speech in multiple languages
right and as you would probably guess if
you have a background in machine
learning is that
supervised learning algorithms are way
too simplistic for this and they have
not been successful at this task
and multilingual hate speech detection
is a very very popular research field in
its own right and as of today we have
models that can detect hate speech in
english spanish french arabic chinese
japanese and even code mixed languages
like hindi and english right so
there are a lot of successful
publications in this realm i do urge you
to check it out if you're interested in
this because
finally when we talk about natural
language processing right english is not
just the only natural language out there
right we want
computers to be interfaced with us in
all language to be able to interface
with us in all possible languages right
so this is a very interesting subfield
within the hate speech detection domain
and
yeah i hope i was able to explain you
know
why deep learning is necessary in the
hate speech detection community despite
the
performance of machine learning
classifiers
and yeah so coming
forward and moving on to the next topic
which is when should we use pitch like
when is deep learning supposed to be
used when is machine learning supposed
to be used for these kind of problems
even in general there's no good answer
to this question right i mean there's no
firm answer at least it's not like
there's one specific use case that calls
for deep learning or one specific use
case that calls for machine learning
but there is definitely uh you know
a good rule of thumb that i like to use
which is that deep learning is usually a
good choice for complicated problems
that have a lot of constraints in the
learning environment so like we saw in
our paper uh papers that we just went
over right uh if you want to look for
something that's multilingual or
something that needs both vision and
language basically problems that are
just
more complicated than simple text
classification
deep learning is a good choice
but that being said i personally feel
that it's always good to try out some
supervisor unsupervised machine learning
algorithms at the beginning of any task
just to establish a baseline right
because once you're able to decide uh
you know how well can machine learning
classifiers do you can really quickly
tell whether the problem statement calls
for ensembl learning or whether it calls
for deep learning or you know basically
it just helps you plan out your next
steps in the modeling phase
so
yeah
let's move on to the last part of our
talk today which is um
open source data sets and libraries for
us to use
and in terms of uh
libraries we do have you know pytorch
tensorflow cameras python libraries like
scikit-learn nltk these are all open
source and if you've done any work in
the machine learning community you
already know this but what i thought it
is much more interesting to discuss is
that the data sets right um
we have something called papers with
code and i'm not sure how many of you
are aware of this
but the papers with code has 52 hate
speech detection data sets right so if
you go to that site and you just search
the term hate speech detection data sets
you get 52 results now these data sets
are for racism detection sexism
detection there are
english data sets there are chinese
datasets there are even arabic data sets
so there's a lot of data for you to
already get started with another thing
is that i have a data set hosted on my
github right and
and that is containing of sitcom
dialogues that are annotated for sexism
so if you feel like you want to venture
out into you know detecting sexism in
movies or in tv shows you should
definitely check that out as well
so yeah with that being said that's
about it thank you for being here i hope
you learned something by coming to this
talk and i hope i was able to motivate
you to look into hate speech detection
problems as budding researchers or as
budding ai practitioners thank you so
much